now let's go across the pond where King
Charles prepares for his holiday on the
throne as for the status of the royal
Rift and my understanding is that King
Charles III is going to follow his
mother's tradition and host a family
Christmas at Sandringham this year
Well Harry and Megan have been invited
for Christmas but it's our understanding
that they won't be coming over to the UK
King Charles's newest portrait
commemorating his 74th birthday also
came with an announcement that could be
interpreted as a dig towards Prince
Harry along with that photograph he has
used his birthday as an occasion to
appoint two new councilors of State who
can represent him when he's away on
official business Princess Anne and
Prince Edwards that essentially means
that Charles is not going to be using
Harry as substitute and I think that's
just another probably quite painful
reminder for Harry that he's willing to
be out of the royal family
the king's coronation is set for May 6
Prince William will take on a much more
prom a public role moving forward I
think you're going to see a real Focus
put on the prince and princess of Wale
this projection of a new Fab Four which
I think is really going to come to
Define King Charles's Reign but the king
does face multiple threats to what he
hopes will be an improved image of the
royal family Prince Harry's teller spear
will be released January 10th then
there's the new season of Netflix the
crown which isn't exactly a good look
for Charles and Camilla I saw Camilla
and I just felt till to the bird E.T was
exclusive at the London Premiere with
Dominic West who gave the king a heads
up about recreating some of his biggest
scandals I just thought I'd I would
inform the princess trust that I was
playing the part and and I felt they had
a right to know that well the three of
us marriage when you join the crown the
team there's an enormous amount of
archival footage that is suddenly
available to you so I just sort of dove
in really deep it must be incredibly
frustrating for the king that he cannot
escape from his past and I think the
crown shows that those fears are not
unfounded
[Music]